uh good evening members um we're just
approaching uh seven o'clock
welcome to the cabinet meeting 31st of
august 7 pm
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the offices via the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assemble in halle square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn your mobile
phones to silent and do not make or
receive calls whilst the meet is in
progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
no
the following members have asked to
speak under council procedure rule 20.1
item three councillor wing item four
councillors auburn garner austin bailey
and wing
item
six council ghana
are there any more members requesting to
speak
[Applause]
there are no apologies for absence
declarations of interest does anyone
have any interest to declare in the
items of business on the agenda this
evening
item three minutes of the previous
meeting
do i have a proposal for
the minutes
councillor saunders
do i have a second though
councillor bayfield
councillor wing you've asked to speak
regarding item
three thank you thank you leader you'll
be glad to hear it's quite brief
actually i find it quite strange that
that when a counselor
raises serious concerns or speaks and
raises a concern however serious that
concern is that all that's recorded in
the minutes is that councillor's name so
there's no actual record of what they've
actually discussed or tried to raise
that's my first point my second point is
i remember at that meeting that that you
you kindly asked for me to send that
report to you my speech to you so that
so that the the the paid officer gavin
way at the time could give a response to
all my concerns some of which i think
were fairly serious
thank you
okay thank you councillor wing um i
understand it's not constitutionally um
necessary to recall the actual
um
request
for a response on the report but i will
tell you for your information
that
the report that was sent through you
kindly sent it to me because i'd agreed
to send it on and i sent it to
mr waite and mr humber on the 11th of
august 2021 at 14 10.
so if that can be recorded in the
minutes if that suffices
thank you
item 4 fanet lifts petition
to introduce
councillor pugh
thank you leader the council received a
petition containing 2 180 valley
signatures requesting that the seaside
lifts at viking bay and ramsgate be
reopened
this petition was presented at the full
council meeting on the 3rd of june
2021
a cabinet report is being produced to
cover all the aspects around both lifts
to inform the decision regarding their
future and in the meantime this report
provides an update and further
information about the lifts
i think it's important to note that of
this report or the note in this report
there are no financial implications for
the council um and we will before the
publishing of
the final report be hoping to meet with
local community groups to discuss this
matter further thank you
all right speakers under 20.1 council
auburn
thank you chair um
thank you councillor pugh for that
um
well here we are again
with this uh and his saga
well as the report says dragon
um we've got more episodes than
coronation street
and
i have some issues in relation to
the report that i just like to speak
about one
the report refers to twenty five
thousand pounds have been spent
repairing all the damage components
following a theft of the lead
i think i think it should be
clear in a report that that 25 000 pound
was the insurance claim money that we
got from there and that that money's
been spent on that
um
so it it just gives the that just gives
the um
the
view that 25 000 that the couch was at
the cough up 25 000 pounds to spend
initially on that instead of it being a
an insurance claim
now obviously we're fully fully aware of
the risk the financial restraints that
the council has
none of us are stupid as far as as far
as that is concerned
and obviously i've noted that uh a
further 35 000 pound is required to be
spent in order to get the uh lift
fully repaired and and working
i was hoping uh like
my
colleagues councillor huxley and
councillor crittenden for who i'm also
speaking on behalf
that by now we would we would have had
something uh some money put in place for
this to be uh carried out and done
it's specifically important for ramsey
and i'm
i'm i'm sure
uh certainly they brought our
broadstairs councillors here part of
cabinet know the importance of the lift
for broad stairs
and the amount of um reaction that that
it
produced when uh when it when it wasn't
it wasn't working i'm specifically
talking about the ramsgate lift
it's an important part
of ramsgate's heritage especially in its
location on on the east cliff which is
obviously near to the bandstand it's
near to the waterfall it's near to it's
near to the polar mites of which we just
got grant for to repair
and it's near to west uh to um
everybody
thank you very very much
it's been a long day um and all of those
that they all add up to our heritage
that that we have in ramsay and it's
very important for our residents but
it's also
the the lifting itself is also important
for our
visitors who come along especially uh
disabled ones who who
may be staying above on on the east
cliff and need to get down to the beach
and quite quite rightly so
um
i would just urge
cabinet
that they would bring this report
back
here as soon as possible
and to find the money
is 30 35 000 pounds to spend on the lift
and and to get it going i would also ask
cabinet
uh
to
give the residents of ramsgate uh
a view that this is going to happen
i won't use the word promise that they
will pack that you will pay this because
it's the i can't do that but to give the
residents at least something that they
can uh grab hold of to think that this
the lift will be up repaired and working
as soon as possible because the last
part of the report actually says
that um
the lift the for the the lift will be
closed for the foreseeable future
well what does that mean it doesn't
actually mean anything does it
um you know if if cabinet could give a
view as to how long this this will take
and that they can find the money for
this
uh and and get this done for the
residents and visitors to landscape
thank you chair
thank you council auburn did you want to
come back on that or would you like to
come back at the uh
speakers
okay
um councillor ghana
thank you thank you leader um
well one positive that has come out of
the closure of the lifts at the start of
this summer
was that it's led to a greater awareness
in the community about the difficulty
some of our residents and visitors to
the area have accessing our beaches
but these
when these lifts are unavailable
and the strength of feeling about their
closure has been demonstrated
through mr sticking's petition which has
quickly garnered significant support
and as of yesterday when i checked
4225
people have signed calling for both
lifts to be open to maintain
i agree with councillor alban about the
report because i think it's unfortunate
that the report before cabinet this
evening
is not able to give us after all this
time the full picture of the issues that
need to be addressed and the costs
associated with addressing them
to enable both lifts to be made good and
operational for the future
it reads to me unfortunately like a
like a first step towards a decision to
close them both
um permanently
now rather than this i believe we need a
plan that focuses on repairing and
maintaining these lifts
and not just for the summer season but
for all year round
a large number in our community are
calling for this and they deserve to be
taken seriously
can the cabinet please ask officers in
the preparation of the more detailed
report to outline a plan
that will capture all tasks and
associated costs
so so that a year-round lift service can
be seriously considered in the near
future
thank
you thank you councillor ghana
uh council austin
thank you leader
um
i'm very pleased to note that the viking
bay lift has has been able to be
reopened i'm very concerned about the
east lift lift but as somebody who spent
quite a bit of my professional life
writing funding bids i have to say this
is a classic external grant funding
project it has the potential to draw
funding down
for from the sorts of of funds which
support uh disabled access and inclusion
and also architectural heritage it's a
stunning example as cap as cancer album
has highlighted of our architectural
heritage there is there are
possibilities here for drawing down
funding
i
look across at the director of
regeneration and i'm aware of her tiny
team and her huge commitments
can i highlight this skills and
abilities that we have in our community
in the matter of external funding in the
eastgate community group alone there are
several people who have drawn down
substantial funding for ramsgate
and there is a former extremely senior
civil servant
can i suggest to cabinet that
consultation with the community happens
as soon as possible and that this
includes the possibility of working with
stakeholders to put in substantial
external funding bids in order that
these resources are not lost thank you
thank you council austin we will comment
well we'll finish with um obviously
councillor bailey and then i think we'll
sum it all up there might be more than
one cabinet member that would like to
contribute to the questions and the
answers councilor bailey
thank you
i think previous speakers have all um
put me a bit in the shade
those couldn't
um
i'll carry on anyway um so first of all
speaking as well councillor uh my other
wall councils are here as well um
for viking bay can i express my thanks
for ensuring that the viking baby's lift
lift was open in time for the summer
holidays and it has been a real godsend
to people i'm really welcomed um
although i do uh recognize that round
skate have not been as fortunate
my couple of questions were um
whilst i acknowledged the large sum of
money that has already been spent in
getting the viking bay lift operational
again the report states that there's
still a lot of work to do
so could we have a please have a
commitment that this will be budgeted
for and that the required work to make
the lift fully safe and compliant will
be done as soon as is practicable
um my second
question or point um
makes bit councillor ghana's although
i'm not quite as optimistic as council
garner i know that there is a rather
hopeful call for the lift to remain open
365 days a year but i would hazard a
guess
that this would be deemed as both
unprecedented and financially unviable
by the council
however
and using the principle that if you
don't ask you don't get i wonder if firm
consideration could be given to an out
of season schedule where the lift is
available for popular events such as the
october food festival and during the
christmas and easter holidays
so at least it's open for part of the
out of season not only would this
provide a vital service at those busy
times it would also keep the lift in
running order and help to prove prevent
it seizing up over winter
thank you
thank you councillor bailey um
council pew i'm going to come to you
first but i think sorry leader i was due
to speak under this item as well sorry
i'm sorry
uh obviously we're really pleased that
ball says lift is up and running and in
fact there are two lifts in ramsgate
there is a dysfunctional lift on the
west cliff that we've already lost and
thanks to the western undercliff group
and their funding and i believe working
in association with tdc that lift was
partially restored on the external side
of it so that it didn't continue to
deteriorate and be blighted so it looks
okay though it's not being used we'd
love that one to be in use but that
might be asking too much
i think
i need cabinet i think we need cabinet
to give the people of ramsgate
reassurances that every effort will be
made to provide equity equality of
provisions with regard to beach access
fire lifts
but also to have a working lift of
significant
historical importance which is which is
a a tourist attraction or very often
lifts in other seaside resorts our
tourist attractions they attract people
in and is part of our our our heritage
just in the same way that the lifting
broadstairs is important in terms of
access and heritage
i i echo what what council councillor uh
hartley says in terms of working with
residents we know we have a significant
number of people with the talent to draw
down money i actually work for charlton
athletic and i'm part of a group that
there's drawn down
over half a million pound in the last
five years to keep out our own provision
going for disaffected young people so
that that skill and ability it actually
exists out in the community and i would
urge tdc given our present funding
crisis to make every effort to encourage
those people to step forward and and try
and try to access and start putting in
money that i believe we are losing hand
over fist
although all those groups of people
would need is is one officer to to be
that link or that guide for that group
of people to actually get that money
going we we're desperately short of
finances and we need to explore every
avenue and that means using the talented
people we have out in our community to
make projects like this work thank you
thank you councilwoman apologies again
that i was looking at my old list not my
new one
over to you councillor pugh
thank you leader um yeah i thank
councillors for their questions and for
their comments um i think it's
incredibly important to note that you
know us as an administration but also
all of us as councillors of the council
is that public safety is our number one
priority and it should always be our
number one priority and i look forward
to
the finalizing of the report and what
the report says because i think that
that's something that we all need to
bear in mind
these lifts when they were first
constructed as i'm sure we all know uh
were built in a time when they weren't
adhering to the standards that we would
appreciate and we would expect now
particularly for people that need them
the most so that's another important
consideration um but i take exception to
council ghana's comment particularly
about
deserving to be listened to i think all
of us as counselors listen to residents
on a frequent basis and will continue to
do so on issues such as this
but i don't necessarily think that this
issue is as clear-cut as as some people
will believe it to be and as i said the
public safety is our number one priority
but i'm sure other cabinet members may
have other things to add
counselor bob baffert
yeah thanks chairman um yeah i mean to
echo really what everybody said um i
think we would love to be able to
provide two lifts yeah working 24 7 you
know throughout the year but
um you know recent history has told us
that in order to do that
um it's likely there's going to be major
works need to be done on both lists a
huge expense
and you know
it's a bit ironic really because if you
look at the recent history of broad
stairs um broadcast lifts
uh foreign is a bit facetious but i
think there is some sort of truth in
that um and
you know i think it is a good idea to
look at external grant funding um
and
what i hope that
the message that people take away from
tonight is that it is our commitment to
look at both of these lists see what the
prognosis is because it's no good just
doing a quick fix on them they've got to
be brought up to a standard where
they're capable of running for a number
of years and there's got to be a budget
for maintaining them because the other
thing that's for sure that both of those
structures are going to need
maintenance and if you read this report
here i mean it might be another thing
but it was highlighted in here
to me for the first time looking at the
actual sort of lift shafts and the
structures rather than absolutely
looking at lift and mechanism and
whatever and you start looking at that
and the problem gets bigger so i think
that what we would hope to do is to be
able to work with the community i think
council appears already said that he's
looking to arrange
community involvement in this
and together we can look at what the art
of possible is look at you know trying
to achieve nirvana
but if we can't then we need to
recognize why we can't and you know and
then kind of move on but yeah committed
to doing it
counselor saunders
thank you leader um as a member of the
millennium group in broad stairs which
was fundamental in getting the lift
built in
1999 and 2000
i have a very vested interest in that
lift shaft
i have to say that i'm not so sure that
the lift builds in 2000 or only in 2000
counts for heritage
maybe if we still have the funicular
lift
in broad stairs that may well do
what concerns me is of course uh
councillor bayford has mentioned it we
have issues with regards to the actual
fabric of the lift shaft um
world councillors know that the
um the actual promenade in broad stairs
is moving
anyone that walks along the promenade
will notice that the cracks in the
tarmac adding surface are widening we've
had chalk falls all along onto the
bathing station below
the lower promenade was closed for
several months we've had to move the
beach huts that were there because of
the chalk falls so there is an issue
with regards to the structure
of that
that lift shaft
i've
asked for the costings
i've had some
approximate costings and when we get
down to sitting down and looking at the
budget we will certainly give due
consideration to the costs involved
but it's not just the mechanics of the
lifting broad stairs that are
disappointing me that they haven't
lasted longer than they have um i have
now serious concerns with regards to the
whole structure of the lift shaft
but you have my assurance as someone
that would spent months and months and
months fundraising to get it there in
the first place uh that i will give
my best endeavors in getting a some
money in the budget if possible and b
looking at other funding measures in
order to ensure that lift stays
for another 20 years thank you
thank you council saunders um
i would just like to to add my piece and
um
ask
i will be asking um
the officers to investigate
what sort of funding is out there what
possibilities there might be of various
bids um it's something that i've always
um commented on and i think that'll be
supported by uh
by the cabinet is that i think we
probably do miss opportunities not just
for lifts but for
a lot of areas in this council where we
could go after money um it is a resource
issue
but um
in some ways it sort of self funds if
you can get it off the ground but it's
it's always
it's an eternal circle to try and
to try and get there so um i will um ask
as as we've got the 151 officer with us
tonight um i'll request them perhaps
someone in the team could actually just
have a look to see what sort of
funding could be available i'm not
asking your team to actually uh
prepare a bid but at least if there's
something out or some bids out there
that we could go after and then maybe we
can coordinate some of the um
the expertise that we've got around so
as a sideline to to everything all the
other good work that uh councillor pugh
um and councillor bayford are talking to
the community about so
um a couple of pronged attacks so is
that okay um if i can come to you
mr willis thank you
yes sir my finance team would always
signpost any external funding they
become aware of that's on their radar to
the relevant offices and
um this report before cabinet makes
reference to a further report and i
expect that further report from my
colleagues to include
any funding options that the cost of a
proper refurbishment of one or both
lifts
and options for funding that too and my
finance team would work with those
officers that prepare that report
thank you thank you mr willis um
i'm asking um cabinet to note the report
do members agree
uh item five ah that's me i think uh
statement of community involvement
review uh results of the public
consultation and adoption
the statement of community involvement
sets out how the council will consult on
planning policy issues planning
applications and neighborhood plans
the sci was originally adopted by
council in two thousand seven
a review and updated sci was adopted by
council in twenty twelve
it is considered appropriate that the
sci should be reviewed now in line with
the forthcoming local plan review and to
reflect changes in methods of
communication and engagement
there is also a requirement under the
town and country planning regulations
that scis are reviewed every five years
the council carried out a public
consultation on the sci review from the
25th of february to the 9th of april
2021
this report sets out the main issues
raised in response to that consultation
and any con resulting changes to be made
to the sei
subject to agreement by cabinet the
reviewed seo will be reported to full
council for adoption
the council has considered the issues
raised in relation to the sei and some
changes are recommended in annex one
members will recall that concerns are
raised regarding the proposed to change
an administrative fee for processing
lengthy and complex representations into
the local plan
it was not the intention that this
should affect the ability of local
people to make representation and
following the consultation it is
recommended that the proposal is not
included in the sci
the report was considered by osp on the
26th of august and they agreed the
recommendation without further amendment
to the sci
i move the recommendation in this report
councillor bayford
do members agree
item 6
urgent decision amendment to the capital
programme to introduce councillor pew
thank you leader
this report is requesting the approval
of adding an additional scheme into the
capital program from the town's fund
subject to final approvals from the
ministry of housing communities and
local government
the capital funding within our program
will be no more than the total 22.2
million pounds
this being the maximum award for the
delivery of the projects
already agreed for the margate town deal
the council of the accountable body and
as 90 of the funding is capital it needs
to sit within our capital program in
order to be spent on capital projects
all the investment and costs
associated with the market town deal are
fully funded from external grants and
contributions and all expenditure
relating to the interventions will be
managed within the total package of
funding provided to ensure there is no
risk of financial exposure to the
council
i recommend approval that all allocation
that an allocation is made in the
capital programme in order that the
council may receive capital funding from
central government
thank you council pew
councillor bob bae for the second do
members agree
[Music]
that concludes tonight's business
thank you very much i won't um i just
had a couple of brief comments i wanted
to make about um the importance of
openness and transparency in how the
town deal is managed not just because
that's one of the nolan principles but
also because it's the best way of making
sure that the community that the town
deal is being delivered to benefit
understand why decisions are being made
about how the money is spent
while the report acknowledges the
importance of transparency requirements
being met
along with those other nolan principles
i'll be grateful if
um councillor pugh could just
answer a couple of questions along those
lines
um firstly how how are we going to make
sure that all decisions made by the
board are published
and how are we going to monitor how
funds are spent once they are allocated
to a project
well this is of course important for all
elements of the town deal
i think it's particularly important
where money is allocated to projects
which are outside our control like the
four million pound allocated to projects
at dreamland i'll be particularly
interested in knowing how we're going to
be monitoring the spend on these
projects to make sure the money is spent
as intended by any new potential owners
of dreamland
thank you
councillor if i can just come in there
this is just a
constitutional requirement to move the
money from one fund to the other to
enable the spending of um
the the revenue as soon as possible as
the work starts it's purely a formality
through this hasn't got anything to do
with the actual program of work
so this is just to put the mechanism in
place
um i if i can just pass to louise just
to confirm what i'm saying there this is
not trying to avoid your question but
your question is not actually applicable
to this particular
amendment to the capital program but
i'll pass to police
yeah the funding is all capital so it
has to sit within our capital program
and obviously that normally comes to a
full council meeting but as the report
says we have some funding up front to
help deliver the um set up of the
projects and therefore that all needs to
go within the capital program otherwise
we can't spend that money
there's a program of monitoring and
evaluation that we will have to report
on a monthly basis
back to central government about how
we're allocating and spending the money
and we won't get any further funding for
projects until we've
fully spent the money as it comes
through and
accounted for that spending
yes so council of pew
thank you leader yeah and i'm not going
to try and outmatch what louise says
louise is the expert here but what i
would say counselor garner is if they
you have any questions please do
send them to me um any more questions
and i'd be more than happy to
to look into them and come back to you
thank you very much i will do thank you
so thank you members thank you cabinet
and officers and this concludes the
business for tonight's meeting i declare
the meeting closed at oh probably not
what that clock says but
7th 1931. thank you charles have a good
evening